من مشروع ناشئ ولد ليدرس سلوك الشعب
الصيني الى ما يصفه الغرب بالتطبيق
الشيطان الذي غزه هواتف اكثر من مليار شخص
محاربته باتت مشروعا وطنيا
البدايه كانت عام 2012 حينها كانت شركات
وادي السيليكون في امريكا تسيطر على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
وتتسابق وراء تطوير نظام الخوارزميات
الاذكى ولدت منصه الصينيه التي وصفت بوافد
متاخر لن يقدر على منافسه العمالقه
سنوات قليله وتيك توك يكسر احتكار الكبار
لا بل ينافسهم في بلدانهم السر لا يكمن في
خوارزمياته الذكيه فقط بل ايضا في توظيفها
اذ يقضي المتصفحون وقتهم في البحث عن ما
يلبي اذواقهم يعرض تيك توك حريه الخيار
مره واحده ليتكفل الذكاء الاصطناعي بدراسه
نفسيه المستخدمين واحياء رغبات يجهلونها
وهنا الخطر يقول المختصون افراز الدوبامين
او هرمون السعاده في كل مره ينال المحتوى
اعجاب المتابعين الا ان الدوبامين المفرز
يتضاعف حال الاعجاب بمحتوى مفاجئ امر لا
توفره منصه منافسه للتيك توك الحكومات
الغربيه انتقدت امتلاك الصين ملفا نفسيا
عن مواطنيها الذين يواجهون خطر الادمان
لمنتوج اسيوي هي خطوه اولى فقط يليها
الكسل والعزله وانخفاض معدلات التفكير
اما بكين فلم تجد تفسيرا لما يعيشه تيك
توك سوى انه صيني بالنسبه للخبراء تيك توك
مجرد درس عن الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي لا
ينافس البشر بل يتطور على حساب قدراتهم